y
[Música]
este lunes el colegio electoral de eeuu
votará de manera oficial para definir
quién será el presidente de eeuu este
puede ser el último paso para confirmar
el triunfo del demócrata joe biden sobre
donald trump quien insiste en hacer
señalamientos sobre un supuesto fraude
en el proceso electoral
avanza a esta hora o avanzan a esta hora
las conversaciones para intentar
concretar un acuerdo para el retiro del
reino unido de la unión europea el
negociador de la unión europea michel
daini dice que aún hay esperanza para un
pacto pero los principales puntos de
desacuerdo permanecen tenemos los
detalles
y el gobierno de nigeria sigue tras la
pista de los 333 estudiantes que
desaparecieron durante un ataque armado
en el noroeste del país las autoridades
intentan determinar si fueron
secuestrados por los atacantes si
continúan refugiados o si huyeron a
pueblos vecinos
muy buenos días bienvenidos a las
noticias de france 24 soy santiago lópez
gonzález gracias por su sintonía hasta
ahora el colegio electoral de eeuu
votará oficialmente en la jornada de hoy
con este paso que dará oficialmente
certificada o no la victoria del
demócrata joe biden sobre el presidente
de donald trump esto se produce cuando
el mandatario sigue insistiendo en sus
acusaciones de un presunto fraude y
negándose a reconocer los resultados
veamos
ha sido una característica definitoria
del sistema político estadounidense
durante más de 220 años este lunes los
integrantes del colegio electoral cada
uno en representación de un estado de
eeuu emiten sus votos para nominar a
donald trump o joe biden como presidente
el candidato que reciba 270 votos o más
se afirma como el ganador de las
elecciones estadounidenses y se espera
que biden obtenga 306 votos y trump 232
la gente no debería preocuparse porque
el periodo de anterior al año nuevo
genere algún tipo de confusión adicional
o una oportunidad para que donald trump
revoque la voluntad de los votantes en
el colegio electoral fue un compromiso
destinado a lograr un equilibrio entre
quienes quieren elecciones populares
para presidente y quienes no querían
participación pública por lo general es
una formalidad legal pero el proceso
está adquiriendo una importancia
política real este año ya que trump
continúa socavando los resultados de las
elecciones el viernes sufrió la última
de una serie de derrotas ya que la corte
suprema desestimó una demanda liderada
por
para bloquear la victoria de bailén en
otros cuatro estados suizos pero todavía
se niega a admitir que perdió
no ha terminado seguimos y vamos a
seguir avanzando tenemos numerosos casos
locales en algunos de los estados que
fueron manipulados y robados ganamos
cada uno de ellos ganamos pensilvania
michigan y ganamos georgia por un gran
margen giorgi baila los votos del
colegio electoral serán contados y
confirmados en una sesión conjunta del
congreso el 6 de enero consolidando
formalmente la victoria de by the
exactamente dos semanas después será
investido como el presidente número 46
de eeuu y seguimos en eeuu porque allí
comenzó el envío de vacunas a las
diferentes regiones del país para dar
inicio a su plan de inmunización masiva
en un intento por mitigar el impacto de
la pandemia de kobe 19 que ha convertido
a este país norteamericano en el más
afectado con cerca de 16 millones de
personas contagiadas y más de 299 mil
personas fallecidas los lotes de la
vacuna de la dupla facer variante que
salieron de la planta de elaboración en
el estado de michigan en el norte del
país en cajas de hielo seco para
mantenerlas a una temperatura de
conservación
70 grados centígrados un total de 2.9
millones de dosis serán entregadas hasta
el miércoles de esta semana
en otros temas hay expectativa en
bruselas por el avance de la negociación
entre la unión europea y el reino unido-
que permita un acuerdo de retiro de ese
país del bloque comunitario y que
permita concesiones comerciales que
beneficien a ambas partes
bruselas y londres tienen discrepancias
en tres temas puntuales siendo estos el
uso de las aguas británicas para pesca
la relación a futuro entre las dos
partes y la gobernanza y competencia
económica una negociación contrarreloj
para definir un acuerdo lo antes posible
antes del 31 de diciembre del 2020 que
es la fecha en la que debe concluir el
retiro del reino unido- sobre este tema
el negociador de la unión europea michel
barnier se refirió estas fueron sus
palabras
como dijo la presidenta de la comisión
europea úrsula von der leyen es nuestra
responsabilidad continuar con esta muy
difícil negociación
nunca en la historia de la unión europea
hemos negociado un acuerdo tan
importante con un país más vivían y dice
avis comercio de bienes servicios pesca
energía transporte la seguridad
ciudadana nunca hemos tenido que
negociar algo tan importante en tan poco
tiempo solo hemos estado negociando
nueve meses hemos necesitado de al menos
cinco años para todos los acuerdos
anteriores así que le vamos a dar toda
oportunidad a este acuerdo es nuestra
responsabilidad lo que aún es posible si
dejamos a europa y nos vamos hasta el
continente africano allí las autoridades
de nigeria siguen tras la pista de un
total de 333 alumnos de una escuela de
la ciudad de khan cara en el noroeste
del país que desaparecieron cuando
hombres armados atacaron esta localidad
el gobierno intenta confirmar si los
estudiantes fueron secuestrados por los
atacantes o si permanecen en refugios o
en zonas boscosas o en viviendas
abandonadas o si simplemente huyeron a
poblaciones cercanas
usama a mí no es estudiante de la
escuela de ciencias del gobierno de
cantara en nigeria en la noche del
viernes era uno de los muchos
estudiantes de la escuela atrapados en
una redada de hombres armados cientos
fueron secuestrados pero usama y otros
cuatro lograron escapar cuando los
rehenes fueron separados en grupos
pensamos que eran soldados que
intentaban protegernos pero infelizmente
no eran soldados cuando decidí huir
trajeron un cuchillo para matarme pero
me escapé me escondí en la multitud a
partir de ahí dijeron que matarían a
quien intentara escapar entonces comencé
a correr trepando de una roca a otra y
luego a través de un bosque él fue uno
de los afortunados el domingo varios
padres se congregaron en la escuela en
busca de respuestas sobre el paradero de
sus hijos
abubakar lawal viajó más de 120
kilómetros sólo para darse cuenta que
dos de sus tres hijos figuran entre los
desaparecidos
recibí una llamada de alguien indicando
que había un problema en la escuela y
que él estaba allí con mi hijo he estado
aquí desde ayer
la presidencia de nigeria emitió un
comunicado declarando que los militares
localizaron el escondite de los
asaltantes en un bosque cercano al área
parece que una tercera parte de los
niños se escapó cuando los hombres
armados que viajaban en motocicleta se
los llevaron no está claro cuántas
personas siguen secuestradas o que
quería el grupo varias de estas
organizaciones ilegales secuestran con
el objetivo de pedir rescates en esta
región de nigeria
en otros temas este lunes una buena
parte de américa del sur se prepara para
presenciar un eclipse total de sol que
podrá ser visto en países como ecuador
perú bolivia brasil uruguay paraguay
pero sobre todo en el extremo sur de
argentina chile y en las islas malvinas
según expertos por espacio de 24 minutos
la luna se interpondrá entre la tierra y
el sol provocando oscuridad total
andrew amaya nos cuenta más
los chilenos se preparan para uno de los
fenómenos más increíbles que puede
ofrecer la naturaleza este lunes la luna
nueva pasará por la cara del sol y lo
cubrirá completamente durante un poco
más de 120 segundos bueno nosotros este
viaje lo veníamos programando del
eclipse anterior que fue en vicuña
entonces vinimos 40 y 45 amigas más o
menos en un bus y con todas las medidas
que se y hoy esperamos ver el evento son
pocos los turistas extranjeros que se
atrevieron a viajar al país suramericano
el cual posee los cielos más limpios del
mundo para la observación estelar
estamos aquí para medir la desviación de
la luz alrededor del sol durante el
eclipse para obtener el coeficiente de
einstein que se llama el experimento de
eddington de expert el eclipse tendrá
lugar en plena pandemia de kobeny 19 por
lo que las autoridades chilenas ya
prepararon protocolos para evitar
aglomeraciones pero esto no será un
problema para el astronauta chris
cassidy a más de 400 kilómetros sobre la
tierra
en estos tiempos de grandes cambios el
universo nos invita a hacer una pausa
para observar nuestro alrededor y
disfrutar del eclipse solar en chile en
su par frenado por ahora todos los ojos
está sobre chile donde veremos el día
convertirse en noche disfruta la
experiencia enjoy the experience
el evento podrá observarse parcialmente
en varios países de américa del sur como
perú bolivia uruguay y paraguay pero
será en chile y argentina- donde se
podrá apreciar en su totalidad en países
como colombia se podrá ver en cambio una
lluvia de meteoros en el cielo hasta el
17 de diciembre
y con esto llegamos al final de las
noticias aquí en france 24 más
información en france 24 punto com en
las redes sociales y en la app siga con
nosotros buenos días
[Música]